[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas und
ich bin selbst herder sportler und heute
im sport reporter freue ich mich dass
ich den dreifachen kletter weltmeister
zugs führer jakob schubert begrüßen darf
herzlich willkommen hallo wie geht's dir
in diesen schwierigen zeiten alles gibt
dir doch soweit das gut bin gesund immer
negativ getestet worden und darf
zumindest da bei uns in die klare und
trainieren vor dem herr das wichtigste
dann geht es mir gar nicht leiden darf
das heißt du fühlst dich beim klettern
der heimatort fühlst du dich am wohlsten
dann kommen wir auch gleich darauf
zurück wie du zum klettersport gekommen
bist und warum du dich so wohl fühlt
aber das hat gesagt immer negativ
getestet worden und damit alles passt
und wir trainieren können
wie wahr in dieser ganzen schwierigen
zeit mit erster locker und weiter
lockern und alles was noch gekommen ist
für euch die möglichkeit dass hier
trainiert wie habt ihr lösungen gefunden
wie waren die präventionskonzept
erzähler mal von all diesen dingen ja
gott sei dank ist das training angeht
schon relativ gut gegangen einer ganzen
zeit unser verband hat sagt da wirklich
extrem bemüht dass wir trotzdem immer
relativ gute trainingsmöglichkeiten
haben also natürlich beim ersten
lockdown haben ja zeit lang nicht in die
kletterhalle dürfen haben irgendwie
andere lösung finden müssen
da hat unser verband eigentlich eben
schnell reagiert und so über
youtube-videos von unseren trainern dann
live gestreamt wo man halt dann alle im
garten am griffbrett hängen oder
manchmal auch ein campus bord was hat
trainingsgerät für kletterer ist gebaut
und hat schon spross fit machen solche
sachen was mal einfach ohne irgendwelche
geräte machen kann dass man mit halbwegs
in form bleiben
und ja dann haben wir zeigen hier
relativ schnell wieder in die halle
dürfen und jetzt beim zweiten lockdown
hatte die zusatz regel gegeben dass die
spitzensportler show trainieren dürfen
vor dem er hat uns das jetzt weniger
getroffen und da haben die möglichkeit
alle dürfen das was natürlich das jahr
schon sehr speziell gemacht hat ist dass
man fast gar keine wettkämpfe cup haben
vor allem auf internationaler ebene
das war schon sehr außergewöhnlich sage
mal natürlich war eigentlich das jahr
geplant das sehr wichtige jahr zu sein
mit mit den olympischen spielen das war
natürlich
das ziel der groß aufzuzeigen und eine
medaille zu gewinnen und das hat er
schon da steht man manchmal vielleicht
schon kurzes linda lehrer und muss sich
andere ziele setzen aber das ist mir
ganz gut gelungen von mr
würde es trotzdem positiv ist es wäre ja
die olympia premiere nicht nur für dich
gewesen sondern auch für deine sportart
und dann ist eben wie du schon gesagt
hast verschoben worden wir hoffen
natürlich dass alles wie geplant jetzt
so stattfinden kann
dass auch diese kurze lehrer
angesprochen wie ist es dir wirklich
ganz konkret mit das datum gegangen als
die nachricht gekommen ist du wirst
nicht den gipfel geben können bei den
spielen 2020
ja es wurde in der doch nicht einfach
ganz so vom einen auf den anderen tag
als natürlich ein bisschen kommen sehen
dass das einfach nicht funktionieren
wird da in diesem jahr die olympischen
spiele ja das dass sie stattfinden
werden
vor einem jahr habe dann schon ein
bisschen damit gerechnet ich muss sagen
als kletterer hat ein bisschen das glück
das man nicht komplett von wettkämpfen
abhängig ist
wir haben doch haben wir das
felsklettern wo man sich ziele setzen
kann wo man wo man sich entwickeln kann
und zeigen kann was man wirklich drauf
hat der ganzen welt das ist als
ehrgeizling hat auch irgendwie wichtig
und vor dem meer habe heuer am kassa
vielen versen realisieren können und man
da eben irgendwie ziele gesteckt und so
die motivation verloren und hat
natürlich sofort versucht und das tue
ich immer noch das als chance zu sehen
dass die olympischen spiele ein jahr
verschoben sind einfach als chance
nochmal besser zu sein sich noch besser
vorzubereiten und ja einfach mehr zeit
zu haben in die form des lebens zu
kommen so zu sagen du hast jetzt auch
das felsklettern angesprochen wie kann
man sich dann den unterschied beim beim
effektiven klappt dann forschte man ja
klar dass eine halle und das andere ist
draußen in der natur aber was verändert
sich am element klettern selbst wenn man
irgendwann fels hängt und nicht in der
halle im griff wir haben auf ein land
das natürlich schon einige sachen also
man das ganz klarer sind dadurch meist
einfach in der natur oft in den bergen
beim felsklettern geht es nicht immer
nur rein um die leistung jetzt kann es
sein dass einfach nur schöner tag mit
freunden freundin und kollegin im freien
ist und seine zeit verbringt
andererseits vom rhein klettern die
kleider technischen her ist natürlich am
fels einfach viel weniger vorgegeben
in der halle ist es viel leichter zu
erkennen wo mehr klappt dann muss wie
man das zu klettern hat weil man einfach
nur die vorgegebenen griffe vor sich hat
am fels muss man das ein bisschen mehr
für sich finden und vor dem eis manchmal
technischen anspruchsvoller 2021 in
tokio wird der cutter bewerb war das
kombinations bewerb ausgetragen
in der kletterszene wird das sehr
kritisch gesehen wie stehst du zu diesem
kombinations bewerbt eben erstmalig
ausgetragen wird
also man kritische money gab es sind
schlussendlich die wettkampf kletterer
und einfach sehr viele verbände und
überhaupt athleten natürlich sehr
dankbar dafür
das kletternetz endlich olympisch ist
das bei den olympischen spielen ist das
verschafft unser sport auch einfach
einmal mehr aufmerksamkeit und hilfe der
vielen athleten finanziell natürlich so
muss man schon sagen
andererseits hat man einfach die
kompromisslösung eingehen müssen dass
man dabei ist dass man nur die
kombination hat von uns daran ist
natürlich die große hoffnung dass wir
irgendwann einmal unsere drei
disziplinen als einzeldisziplinen was er
spricht drei medaillen-entscheidungen
haben werden
jetzt müssen wir dabei mit dem
kompromiss leben immer sagen ja ich
bin's trotzdem geil das manchmal bei
olympia dabei sein und wir haben schon
bislang die kombination gewöhnt und
hofft dass ja in der sehr gut
abschneiden kann
21 24 in paris ist ja schon der erste
schritt gesetzt dass das sozusagen
aufgeteilt wird da gibt es dann zwei
bewerbe einen kombination aus verstieg
und bruder so weit ich das jetzt richtig
verstand hat da gebe ich bitt und der
speed bewerb eben einzeln also zwei
medaillen entscheidungen für den
klettersport also anscheinend geht es in
die richtung die du dir auch wünscht ja
genau es war die richtige richtung
also ja logischerweise weit daneben
jetztzeit von d 3 auf die zwei
disziplinen ist wieder neue
kombinationen die was eigentlich
entwickelt wird sprich wieder anderer
kompromiss also kommt kombination aus
lied und boulder und
der speed ist abgebildet ist schon mal
sehr wichtiger schritt in die richtige
richtung als bieter einfach sehr anders
ist wie die zwei schwierigkeit
disziplinen und die hoffentlich
natürlich 228 dann in weiter ferne
unsere drei disziplinen aber schauen wir
mal
wenn du über olympia spricht sieht man
die freude an ich meine du bist schon
sehr lange im klettersport tätig als mit
zwölf jahren angefangen und bis doch
schon sehr sehr lange in der weltspitze
aktiv wird 2012 in paris weltmeister
permanent weltcupsieger die du lieferst
und eben 2018 doppel weltmeister bei der
heim weltmeisterschaft in innsbruck also
du dominiert den sport auch
international ein bisschen mit hat es
lieber diesen traum das klettern
olympisch wird damit du auch einmal
olympia luft schnuppern kannst oder war
das etwas das du da einfach gerne
genommen hat die entscheidung getroffen
wurde
ich muss sagen als jugendlicher habe man
in so viel gedanken darüber gemacht also
natürliche bin immer schon ein extrem
sportbegeisterter mensch habe als kind
und jugendlicher immer schon sehr viele
andere sportarten mitverfolgt im
fernsehen geschaut und natürlich auch
die sommer olympischen spielen und es
ist einfach das größte sportereignis was
es gibt vor allem wo ich dann zum ersten
mal davon gehört ob das ist vielleicht
schon die möglichkeit gibt dass da
klappt dann irgendwann einmal dabei ist
weil es schon irgendwie großer
hoffnungsfunken und natürlich wo dann
klar war es wird olympisch wasser vor
großes ziel bei seiner veranstaltung
einmal dabei zu sein weil es extrem
legendäres event ist und da ist schon
großer ärger da ist sportler vielleicht
einmal dabei sein zu dürfen
wie wird der klettersport in japan oder
in asien gelebt gesehen glaube es wird
das dann ein spektakel weil einfach die
fans auch auf diese wirklich spannende
von außen sport hat sich schon so freuen
oder glaubst du dass das waren das dann
noch einmal besser sein könnte
ich habe mir wissen noch nicht genau wie
bisher oder wie normal das ablaufen kann
das event wähler wirklich so viel
zuschauer haben dürfen
mal schauen hoffentlich natürlich aber
schauen wir mal auf jeden fall ist japan
glaube ich einer der perfektesten länder
um die premiere des kletterns bei
olympia zu feiern
in japan ist schon seit sehr vielen
jahren vor allem im bouldern aber auch
in den anderen disziplinen ganz vorne
dabei also da gibt es sehr viele
athleten die was zur doppelte gehören
und klettern ist ein verräter schon seit
einigen jahren vor allem in tokio extrem
am boomen
heute gibt es zahllose kletterhallen
also ich glaube es gibt keine stadt auf
der welt was merkblatt teilen hat das
tokio und immer wenn ich dort bin ist
ein wahrer extrem viel los in die hallen
und der sport wird dort sehr positiv
aufgenommen vor allem glaube ist es
super dass wir dort die premiere feiern
oder sport boomt auch in österreich das
liegt sicher auch an euren jüngsten
erfolgen
wie glaubst du ist dass neben dem auch
noch zu erklären und dass so viele
menschen derzeit in österreich klettern
wollen ja es gibt schon richtig sachen
boomers immer nicht glauben natürlich
immer an mir doch die sportart extrem
vor dem museum für die spieler machten
mega sport und hat jetzt ein bissel mehr
aufmerksamkeit die letzten jahre
erhalten und so kann man einfach mehr
leute dazu auch die sportler
auszuprobieren
es ist kein verrat dollar satz
vielleicht leute was unbedingt fit
bleiben wollen aber nicht so
lust aufs fitnessstudio haben es ist
zudem einfach glaube ein guter satz der
was einfach einmal sozialleistung es ist
ein sehr sozialer sport gerade das
bouldern das was vielleicht am meisten
um das einfach mega metabo kollegen
gemeinsam abholer problem versuchen zu
lösen
es gibt immer mehr bohlen und das sind
einfach richtig gut aufgestellt das ist
einfach richtig cooler infrastrukturen
wo man einfach richtig viel spaß an der
sportart haben kann man glaubt das
entdecken immer mehr leute vor allem ein
städter für sich merkst du da auch dass
der zulauf für den wettkampfsport dann
dadurch automatisch kommt oder ist das
eigentlich getrennt dass ich die ganzen
breitensport im klettern und der
wettkampfsport oder wenn das eine
profitiert profitiert auch das andere
mir wird schon sagen das ist eine vom
anderen profitiert das einfach dadurch
dass einfach mehr leute ahnung vom
klettern haben
lesen auch mehr leute gern davon in der
zeitung
dann bringt es die zeitungen flattr ist
fernseher wieder lieber natürlich wenn
die einschaltquote irgendwo extrem hohe
ist dann wollen sie das nächste mal
nächste mal auch wieder bringen
vor dem meer profitiert man auch schon
voneinander glaube ich was bei dir
damals also wie hast du mit dem
klettersport angefangen
du bist aus innsbruck vielleicht liegt
das dort eher auf der hand als in
anderen regionen unseres landes ist das
genau war passiert
naja eigentlich war er als kind eher auf
fußball laufen also eher mit sechs
angefangen fußball spielen und ein bis
zwölf habe ich im verein fußball
gespielt und dann kurz bevor 12 vorn bin
hat mir einmal meiner laufbahn mit
nummern in die quartal in innsbruck
damals eben nur die kleine halle tivoli
und ich bin dann da jede woche einmal
klettern gegangen was man für spaß
gemacht hat und bin dann eben damals
schon vom trainer oder der was jetzt an
mein langjähriger trainer wann ist eine
reine frage war ob wir mal ins klettert
im training rein schnuppern will und
deshalb gemacht haben wir ausprobiert
und das hat mal klein mega spaß gemacht
vor allem die leute was da mit trainiert
haben also habt einfach gleich sehr
tiefe freundschaften geschnürt und
dadurch bin ich dann einfach voll beim
klettern primavera halbes jahr fußball
und klappbares versuch zu machen und mit
anfasst dann entschieden und das war auf
jeden fall die richtige entscheidung
gehasst fast alles gewonnen was man eben
schon gewinnen kann bis jetzt und jetzt
kommt heute nach olympia
also dass beteiligen ist dass man auch
noch potenziell gewinnen könnte hast du
dir am anfang dann auch träume ziele
visionen gesetzt was du alles erreichen
möchte ist im klettersport oder hast du
die dinge einfach so genommen wie sie
dann passiert sind ja ich glaube das ist
ja eigentlich eher schritt für schritt
kommen also natürlich klettern
angefangen aber bezieht das ziel kam
anwälten oder ja schon das ziel aber
jetzt noch nicht haben natürlich gewusst
irgendwann weltmeister werden wir waren
ja schon fast nur im schatten anderer
sage ja mal und das hat man glaube ich
sehr viel geholfen dass sie zudem worden
was sie was sie jetzt bin also wir haben
einfach andere riesentalent und sport
line in innsbruck apa damit dass zum
beispiel david lama kilian fischhuber
angela eiter in imst und so also einfach
andere spitzenkletterer geben von der
sehr viel lernen haben können und wo
eben ein bisschen aus dem schatten der
ada vorrücken können
du warst mit zwölf angefangen das setzt
das schon gesagt ist dass er später er
früh da ist es egal in ketten
ja er wird schon sagen dass es zu spät
ist also keine zeit weniger was so spät
angefangen haben die meisten fangen
natur stück früher an
wer also bei mir wasser kein großes
problem natürlich metern ein bisschen
später entwickeln und eben wie gesagt
sie war zuerst natürlich sehr weit weg
wir jetzt jemanden wie im david lama der
war genau gleich alt wie ihr aber
natürlich sehr viele jahre voraus
einfach und habe dann schon bei jahre
braucht um darauf zu schließen
das war enorm wichtig war ist dass sie
nicht nichts danach bis sie zwölf war
sondern halt andere sportart macht habe
und auf gelernt habe was es heißt zu
trainieren hart an sich arbeiten und mir
ein paar ja vielleicht andere scheinbar
athletisch weiterentwickelt habe vor dem
er habe dann aber schnell im klettern
krabbeln lernen können
das heißt davon profitiert dass du
allgemein mehr mehr sportarten mäßig
unterwegs warst du hast wie gesagt schon
einiges gewonnen und ich hab hier stehen
die besten kräfte erfahrungen die
begehung von geplanter der shiva 9w
erzähler mal was ist das genau was
versteht man darunter und warum war das
eine deiner besten kräfte erfahrungen
sind inzwischen eher schauen noch einige
andere dazu kann man also plant toshiba
ist eine der schwersten roten was wir
bis jetzt geklettert bin am felsen eben
wie für uns gladbacher weitkamp enorm
wichtig aber für viele fans und vor
allem auch mich ist es klar dass mega
wichtiges und das sagt uns extrem
unfalls kann man sich extrem
weiterentwickeln es gibt einfach guten
auf der welt gehören zu die
allerschwersten routen der was es gibt
der gegner nie verloren sprich in 20
jahren kann man immer nur über die reden
und kann jemand immer noch die rote
probieren de was sie damals geklettert
bin das macht irgendwie cool also
einfach ja in stein gemeißelt ist
sozusagen
oder wollt deutlich und ja das sind
versucht sagt dann oft so schwer
rothenfels aus und versucht in der
einfach alles zu optimieren dass man sie
irgendwann schafft und alland mal auf da
sehr viel über sich selber als kletterer
weil man eben perfekt klettern muss für
sich um die route zu schaffen und lernt
dann was ist eine horst perfekt zu
klettern was heißt eigentlich effizient
zu klettern wie kann ich mal nah an
funken kraftsport um die route zu
schaffen und wenn man da lang arbeitet
und die rute raus zu kommen und ist dann
natürlich mega gefühl wenn man das
desktop erreicht 99 beten ist
wahrscheinlich schwierigkeitsgrad oder
denken verzierung
das ist perfektes klettern angesprochen
beim sport sagen wie man ich spüre das
wasser versteht natürlich keiner was wir
damit meinen und das man halt das in
einen flow gefühl kommen wie kann man
sich dieses perfekte ketter gefühl
vorstellen kannst das beschreiben
okay man das kann kann mir gut da darin
identifizieren als er sagt wir haben
zwar nicht ein ausdruck für den versen
aber eigentlich wird es vielleicht es
ihn warten das zu sagen
und ja genau dann in den floor einkommen
das ist genau das gleiche bei uns also
wenn man mal voll in einem flow ist und
trat als im wettkampf zum beispiel da
klettern wir die route er immer zum
ersten mal sprich es wird fast nie
passieren dass wir die route wirklich
perfekt klettern
da schleichen sich immer irgendwas
kleinen fehler ein grad es ist oft so
cool wenn man irgendwas schwere rote am
fels sehr lange probiert weil er
probiert man es wirklich so lang das ist
dann wirklich irgendwann vielleicht
vorkommt dass man sie perfekt klappt
einfach keinen einzigen ganz kleinen
fehler macht
das heißt ich muss einfach überhaupt
nicht nachdenken wenn in die route
kletter weil alles so eingeschliffen ist
und optimiert dass sie da ja
eigentlichen kopf ausschalten und
einfach indem flow drin bin und nichts
mehr denkt außerdem eine fokus und das
ziel der stalker mutter zu erreichen ist
das gefühl dass doch konservieren kannst
wurde dann später vielleicht von von
diesem gefühl dann profitiert dass du
das erleben konntest oder vielleicht
auch beim anderen beklettern der der
route dass das wieder kommt also ist das
etwas was konservierter ist oder er
ja schon als immer ein gewisses maß von
dem flow erreicht man eigentlich die
ganze zeit beim klettern oder habe gab
beim sporteln also das gefühl kein
schuss sicher oder wenn man wenn man
einfach an seine grenzen geht dann kommt
man immer in seinem gewissen flow warum
einfach so konzentriert und fokussiert
ist weil man einfach gut so am zweiten
ist und da wird man natürlich immer
wieder an die ganz tollen momente wo man
den flow drinnen war erinnert wie in
einer schweren roten fels oder in seiner
besten leistung bei irgend ein wettkampf
ist das auch etwas das man braucht um
zum beispiel gerade beim festgeld dann
stelle ich mir vor dass dieser gedanke
dass stürzte jedoch möglich sind dass
verletzungen vielleicht möglich sind ist
das etwas aus einem im hinterkopf mit
klettert oder kann man das gut
abschalten weil man ebenso konzentriert
ist
ja es scheint immer komplett da passiert
ist überzeugend klagt eine extrem
sichere sport oder sie haben jetzt noch
nie wirklich bei einem sturz verletzt
damit andere partner das schon sehr
erfahren sind und sei gut sichern können
von dem her wenn man wenn man ja wenn
das klappt daraus gut drauf hat und wenn
das sicher gut drauf war dann passiert
normalerweise wirklich nix aber
natürlich kann es manchmal sein dass man
an echten großen sturz macht vielleicht
gerade beim bouldern gibt es vielleicht
ein blöder stürze macht man auf die
matten als auf einem felsen beim
wettkampf ist sowieso immer alles voller
sicher aber sowas wie angst scheute man
natürlich schon komplett aus wenn man in
den flow ist und das muss man es ist
eben auch ein bisschen gefährlich
forscher warnen so zu sagen welche
schlicht weil am fels kommt zwar ständig
vor dass man einige von den schlingen
auslöst und nicht ein hängt weil man
sich natürlich jedes bisschen kraft
sparen will was geht
aber man muss das schon so viel
einbringen dass man im fall eines
sturzes erhalt immer noch sich also
nicht auf den boden folgt das ist auch
den aspekt des kraft des sparens
angesprochen ich habe im sommer 20 20
zum ersten mal einen wettkampf von euch
live gesehen bei diesem sommer
wettkämpfen die der kette verband
gemacht hat und da hat mich fasziniert
dass ihr als ihr herausgekommen seitz
aus eurem bereich und dann die route zum
ersten mal gesehen habe ich glaube dass
einen boulder wettkampf wenn ich jetzt
nicht
weil ich mir gemerkt habe und dass er
mal überlegen musste wie gehe ich dieses
problem an weil man wahrscheinlich eben
mit seinen kräften haushalten muss und
in der vorgegebenen zeit diese route zu
lösen gibt es der verschiedenen
strategien die man wählen kann zuerst
einmal probieren und schnell scheitern
damit man dann schneller wieder problem
kann oder welchen lösungsansatz willst
du da man von dem unterscheidet sich
natürlich das bouldern sehr vom vorstieg
klettern
aber ich würde sagen beide disziplinen
ist taktik natürlich sehr wichtiger
aspekt eigentlich gerade in bologna
der große unterschied zwischen ball und
forschung ist dass sie im vorstieg habe
ich nur den einem versuch
und wenn er in die hosen geht dann ist
vorbei und im bouldern habe meine zeit
meine fünf minuten auf den boulder und
darf so oft probieren wie will aber
natürlich ist sehr wichtig den ball so
schnell wie möglich zu klettern weil die
versuche erzählen spricht man ja mal
versuchen jemand anderer für den bohrer
braucht dann weil hinter ihm liegen und
deswegen ist natürlich oft der erste
versuch extrem wichtig weil es beste was
man auf den bola schaffen kann ist ein
erster versuch gleich zu lösen und
deswegen nimmt man so scharf da relativ
viel zeit denn dollar gleich richtig gut
durchzuplanen dass der erste versuch
hoffen nach kleider allerbeste ist als
das nicht geklappt hat habe ich bei
einigen seiner kollegen auch gesehen
dass sie sich sehr stark geärgert haben
also dieses im moment ärgern und
vielleicht aber dann doch drüberstehen
müssen gibt es dafür taktiken damit man
sich eben nicht merken sozusagen
ablenken das gibt der mentale werkzeuge
der verwendet oder muss man das einfach
in dem moment durch leben
ich glaube da gibt es verschiedene
strategien und natürlich auch vor allem
sehr verschiedene persönlichkeiten die
anderen als mehr die anderen weniger
das habe ich immer zum beispiel extrem
beeindruckend dann die japaner gefunden
zumindest nach außen hin aber ich glaube
schon dass nach innen in asow ist
deswegen sind sie ja so erfolgreich im
bouldern kommt mir vor dass sie davon
nichts draus bringen lassen und das sei
etwas was sie natürlich versucht habe zu
lernen über die über die letzten jahre
als als kletterer durch als er gerade im
bouldern ist es enorm wichtig wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel einen ersten boulder
winters hat und mal richtig schlecht
worden war war es dann haben schon fünf
leute
oft und irgendwie geschafft hat schaut
es schlecht aus aber es kommen nur drei
bohrer ist es natürlich enorm wichtige
fähigkeit komplett abzuschalten das den
meisten über abgegeben hat und in der
zweiten reihe zu starten als der erste
und ja das ist manchmal schwieriger als
sie dass es jetzt gerade beschreibt aber
es ist ja wichtige fähigkeit das sehr
spannend wieder der kopf auch mit
kletterrosen das jetzt blöd klingt wir
haben schon angesprochen auch richtung
paris und hoffentlich der wunsch los
angeles 20 28 dass es dann die
einzelbewerbe sozusagen gibt wenn du
noch weiter in die zukunft zu schauen
möchtest und das ultimative in deinem
sport was du noch erreichen möchtest was
wäre das wenn du das benennen müsste ist
ja im mai neben olympia sind die show
sei man sehr viel anfassen also es gibt
schon enorm viele sachen was sie am fels
einfach erreichen macht also 224 er
immer auf jeden fall neues großes ziel
bei olympia gesetzt
wie lang ganz normale wettkampf karriere
weitergeht kann jetzt noch nicht
beantworten
aber gerade am weißen glaube ich mein
ganzes leben lang noch tätig sein
hoffentlich noch einige jahre auf sehr
hohem niveau also macht natürlich schon
versuchen an festen neue maßstäbe zu
setzen die schwersten routen der welt
klettern und probieren und dann
irgendwann natürlich wenn es vielleicht
von der fitness seien immer lang für die
allerschwersten drohten irgendwelche
anderen abenteuer erleben dass
irgendwelche big war es wie im yosemite
was vielleicht direkt von dem free solo
film kennt aber andere sachen es gibt
immer noch viele felsen zu entdecken auf
der welt glaube die was noch nie
beklettert worden sind wo man neue
routen einrichten kann also potenzial
gibt es genügend ist es auch etwas was
dich an der sportart fasziniert dass es
eben neben dem klassischen
wettkampfsport noch so viele dinge und
elemente gibt die man auch vielleicht
lebenslange machen kann
ja auf jeden fall also klappt dann ist
so unglaublich vielfältig und das gefühl
kann einfach nie langweilig werden in
der sportart als im wettkampf klappt
dann ist es extrem abwechslungsreich man
jedes training ist gefühl dass man
irgendwas komplett neues macht weil man
neuen zug macht vielleicht ein ganzer
neuen griff findet also gerade weil sie
sowieso so dass es immer
ganz neue facebook haben kann andere
strukturen angriff was man noch nie
gesehen hat da geht es dann irgendwie um
das landschaftliche oft dass man
irgendwie an einem fleck ist wo man
davor noch nie war also ja gibt es viel
zu erleben
also auf jeden fall noch ganz viele
dinge die du machen kannst wenn du jetzt
mit deinem wissen mit dem was du jetzt
alles heißt kannst erlebt hast deine
mich mit 12 oder vielleicht sogar schon
vorher ein paar ratschläge geben
möchtest oder müsstest was würdest du
dir selber so mitgeben
ja man muss sagen ich bin mit meinem
lebensweg ist sehr zufrieden und stolz
darauf von dem was ich gar nicht so viel
sagen wird macht mal weil er lieber ganz
normaler jugendlicher kind weil da ist
man irgendwie noch so frisch und kann
alles noch mal neu erleben
aber ja immer natürlich vielleicht über
gerade wenn sitzungen wettkampfsport
aghet und dann ab tipps geben wie es
auch solche schweren sachen angehe
egal was jetzt zum beispiel im sport
einfach immer extrem wichtig ist ist es
selbstvertrauen und dann sagt selber zu
glauben zum beispiel glaube hätte viel
früher schon so schwere routen am
felsklettern können wenn ich gewusst
hätte dass sie das drauf habe arbeite
aber mit 18 19 habe immer gedacht waren
alles ist weit über meinen können und es
brauche gar nicht probieren und über
mega wird sagen die einen
das gab es dafür einen prägenden moment
einen moment wo du gesagt hast
ich kann das wirklich also irgendwas was
dich richtig geprägt hat ich habe das
schon bausachen momente geben also wie
der forscher angesprochen aber was jetzt
zum beispiel für meine entwicklung
einfach extrem wichtig war war das in
innsbruck so viele andere
spitzenathleten am trainieren wollen und
die gab es hat mir schon extrem viel
bedeutet und viele meinem kopf
verursacht wo er einfach gesehen ab hey
das sind david lama oder der kilian
fischhuber und essen an der weltspitze
und opera kann ich im training schon mit
dem mithalten ich bin vielleicht gar
nicht so weit von denen weg kann
vielleicht sogar anzug oder am pool
erschaffen wir sie nicht schaffen und
das verursacht natürlich in einem
jugendlichen schon sehr vieles was sie
in der formel sehr viel selbstvertrauen
haben und das hilft dann extrem um bei
bewerber erfolgreich zu sein und aktuell
in innsbruck sind ja auch ich glaube
15 herres sportlerinnen und sportler
oder ein insgesamt für den klettersport
also sehr viele fallen ferne für eine
frische junge olympische sportart
glaubst du dass auch ein erfolgsrezept
dass der sport in zukunft wachsen kann
und erfolgreich sein kann
ja denke schon also natürlich so wie es
damals da david kiliani ban hoffe dass
er irgendwann einmal so jemand für
unsere jugendlichen ärztin spruch sein
kann und mithelfen kann dass sie sich
genauso entwickeln wie jedes hauptmann
da das haus nicht das immer fertig
entwickelt habe bei sega ihr habt immer
noch sehr viel zu lernen und da hilft es
natürlich dass andere spitzenathleten in
innsbruck trainieren gerade die jungen
haben oft ganz andere ideen oder
vielleicht ganz neue techniken der was
man davon und nie gesehen hat von der
jahren wieder profitieren kann vor dem
profitieren wir alle voneinander und ich
hoffe dass das richtige rezept ist so
dass mir ja 224 vielleicht die tore
jessica und mir sondern nur bei anderen
dabei haben du bist ja sicher für viele
in einer sportart auch ein großes
vorbild
jetzt wird es mich interessieren was das
für dich persönlich so bedeutet wenn du
weißt dass andere menschen die ihr
nacheifern danach streben
das bedeutet mir natürlich viel und ist
eine große ehre aber natürlich schwer
große verantwortung und da ich versuche
mir schon nahe dazugeben und sprichwort
oder auch dann auch zu verhalten also
versuche schon vorbildlich zu trainieren
und mich vorbilder zu geben weil ja bei
mir die jungen innsbrucker beobachten
dann will ihnen schweiz zeigen und
anscheinend funktioniert das auch danke
lieber jakob wird ein einblick in seine
gedanken und danke dass du beim sport
report weist und alles gute noch für die
zukunft vielen dank und danke euch fürs
zuhören und zuschauen und ich freue mich
schon beim nächsten sport rapport wieder
auf euch
[Applaus]